they are a royal couple admired by many
around the world but in a small village
in belize the duke and duchess of
cambridge are simply not welcome
the people are
upset about this
indian creek was meant to be the first
stop for the royals as they embark on an
eight-day charm offensive in the
caribbean but now their visit here has
been forcibly scrapped
its indigenous residents said they
weren't consulted about the arrival and
took greater issue with the duke's links
to a conservation charity with which
they're in dispute
it's what we've got a double slap in the
case we can't go to um
buckingham palace and just say well
clear the land we're coming through you
know reverse the role in our case you
have to go to procedure you have to ask
you have to inform people and if you're
allowed then you go ahead so that is
what the committee has decided to say no
this cannot continue to happen
following their protest kensington
palace confirmed that due to sensitive
issues involving the community the
royals visit has been moved to a
different location but a wider issue
around the consequences of the colonial
past remains and it could overshadow
what's being seen as an important tool
there are many of us in this country
that are looking toward becoming a
republic as barbados did as we feel that
we are perhaps entitled to do it's
something that we are
within the
legacy of colonialism and neocolonialism
starting to explore and this trip has
really brought that to the forefront
it was only last year when barbados
removed the queen as its head of state
the royal families see it as up to
individual countries to decide their
futures but there will undoubtedly be an
emphasis on shared interests and working
together even if not everyone wants the
red carpet rolled out for them rhiannon
mills sky news in belize